[Music]
this news today uh
gets a little bit controversial but uh
who's familiar with the name shikari
richardson yes all right who's shikari
richardson she's a olympian uh track
star 100 meter dash
oh yeah yeah that's sure you're right
absolutely right yeah oh she's the one
with the beautiful hair she got positive
for marijuana right is that why she
didn't go right before the
qualifications for tokyo olympics she
ends up just getting disqualified
because she tests positive for having
somebody she was in a kanye music video
after
was she that sounds appropriate
she was in a really cool commercial yeah
so she she never got to be an olympian
oh yeah she didn't get to go she's so
she's young though so she'll she'll get
there she'll get there yeah she was for
sure the fastest sprinter in the world
when it was like she was smoking full
with like 14 inch nails yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's flojo style
she could be
bolt
she could be mr bolt
she could i don't i don't know i don't
think so he's fast she beat him but the
conversation is not a gender thing right
now i didn't know i didn't i was just
thinking if she was the fastest thing
who's like comparing it to the fact that
it's a world record or something yeah
she has she has world records for
sprinting is 100 meters that's her event
i believe so yeah but the problem that
and the reason why this sparks
controversy today is because she sees a
double standard in allowing another girl
camilla vallieva from russia to compete
after testing positive also for a
different uh doping agent but what was
it though testosterone uh no it's a band
it's a band substance some other band
substance but it the essence of it is
still to like allow her to like combat
things like fatigue or blah blah blah
whatever oh wait uh i thought russia
wasn't allowed in olympia they're not
russia it's like it's like russian
federation of states or something like
that
it's like a loophole good loophole it's
a loophole where the country doesn't win
the gold medal but it allows the
athletes to still compete oh
oh is that the where the flag is like
it's weird right it's like it just looks
like a generic one okay yeah so u.s
sprinter chicago richardson is calling
out olympic and anti-doping officials
after russian skater camilla vallieva
was allowed to compete despite testing
positive for a band drug
she says can we get a solid answer on
the difference between their situations
richardson asked on twitter after
mediators ruled that vallieva should be
allowed to skate in the women's
individual competition in beijing the
only difference i see is i'm a black
young lady it's all in the skin
i mean it's also america versus russia
that's a huge difference
and also marijuana the way that the
world sees it is way crazier than the
u.s yeah just because yeah they see it
like it's heroin do they do they say
what kind of dope she was taking yeah it
says uh so thc is on the world
anti-doping agency's list of prohibited
substances but so is triumatas
the drug that was found in the valley of
his test sample i don't understand why
thc is banned the way that like steroids
it's like not all drugs are created
equal i don't know anybody that smokes
weed and becomes better at like being a
physical athlete yeah yeah it's that's
not normal maybe jiu jitsu like i can
see because they there there are people
that create like the whole 10th planet
crew believes in like smoking weed
did say that if you found weed earlier
he'd be a better boxer because it would
calm him yeah
so i guess it's performing enhancing but
it's not something like steroids or it's
a clear-cut enhancing dopamine right
this trimetazidine that was found in
vallejo's test sample is a heart drug
that's believed to be able to boost
athletes endurance and blood efficiency
in other words it can boost athletic
performance while thc does not
yeah i think thc is just a bad substance
because they see it like it's smoking
crack that's why dude the russians
always find a way to like get into the
movie though they should have just
[ __ ] banned her too that is stupid
the skater's defense and i i actually
believe she should be ousted from the
olympics but in her defense they're
saying she's because she's 15
she's she doesn't control what she
ingests
it's not a loophole but it's people are
saying because she's 15 she doesn't know
what she's enjoying she shouldn't be
punished for what her coaches are making
her take the sprinter she and with
intense smoked weed oh yeah yeah it
wasn't like it's like hey hey take this
you know what what is it don't worry
about it trust me and then she took it
has never made somebody faster no but
usually slower yeah i'm surprised she's
so fast
why that's not an argument is because
it's a bad substance yeah yeah
the reasons don't matter but for this 15
year old you know they're saying because
she's 15 she didn't know what she was
taking okay
however having said that the people
responsible should know and so it's
still under the same it's still under
the same still [ __ ] up her chances yeah
yeah yeah yeah richardson who like
valevo was favored to win in a medal uh
in her sport also noted a stark
difference in how their positive tests
were handled while the russian star
failed the test that was submitted in
december she somehow avoided suspension
and the news of the positive tests only
began to trickle out after vallejava
helped her team win a gold medal in
beijing and in contrast richardson said
her drug test was a result quickly
became public knowledge my name and
talent was slaughtered to the people
that's that's down to the country though
that's just how we [ __ ] roll well i
always they did slaughter her i don't
know that's just how the [ __ ] us is
man yeah because i think like so if wada
is the governing agent which is the
world anti-doping agency depending on
how the country handles it handles their
news i think we love drama and we like
to sensationalize that's the
irresponsibility of our press yeah so
our friends will immediately go oh look
at this over there if that news trickles
down the government could probably like
don't [ __ ] believe anything so you
press all that [ __ ] don't don't believe
anything you're here that's just [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is the pride of our
country let's surprise exactly countries
are about looking good to the world and
we're about [ __ ] hate america yeah we
don't hate ourselves so that kind of
rolls back in a different way of how it
actually plays out you know interesting
the other thing too is that
there's no doubt ioc accepts money
there's no i mean there's no doubt um
and there's also no doubt that russia is
willing to pay
to get all the allowances corruption we
do it all the time
how much just tell me like russia yeah
that's the whole the whole documentary
icarus did you watch it yeah yeah i've
heard about it yeah but like in the u.s
no one's going to pay for her no one's
going to know the
a place to sneak pee samples out to go
back and back and through to to make
sure that it was uh they would take out
the one that had their glory holes for
[ __ ] yeah and they would slide it
back in i think it's a i think it needs
updating because now we have to see like
okay so we allow alcohol usage right so
like
athletes being able to drink after they
run or whatever
but um they can't smoke a little weed
because i see them as kind of the same
and maybe alcoholism is a little bit
more dangerous as a substance than thc
so
i don't i don't know what i think it's
an old law that needs to be updated
because what is it about thc that's uh
like harmful and dangerous to the
athlete if it's not enhancing because if
they're gonna say uh
performance-enhancing drugs those
substances are not right are not allowed
in the olympics and then they'll say
okay um
banned substances that are legal for
most countries or whatever like cocaine
heroin whatever you can't do that
because for whatever reason but they
have to have a logical reason i don't
[ __ ] know i know i know i know this i
know it is because i don't do drugs so i
know
so weed
lowers your anxiety and stress levels
right and you're just relaxed
that's part of competition to be able to
handle the stress and anxiety
like with the with the audience because
it's one thing shooting a basket in
front of
your teammates
it's another thing to score a basket in
front of 20 000 people and the olympics
you're talking about hundreds of
thousands and hundreds of millions of
people watching
to deal with that stress and anxiety now
do i 100 believe my theory no however
i'm just offering an option yeah tyson
used to say he would cry a ball in the
locker room before he went into the ring
yeah he just had an anxiety and his fear
was just so crazy to be able to deal
with that and then still perform i think
that's part of because you know michael
jordan talks about um fear like to be
able to drive like i have no fear i i
you know we know because when we watch
him we see it so easily he just drives
the lane and dunks oh it's so easy but
for most people there's a lot of fear
involved will i be able to make it what
if i don't make it um will that foul
will i trip with all these fears that
happen and you've got to be able to deal
with that to become a michael jordan
yeah to become like the best at
something you know jeremy lin is a good
jeremy lin is a good example of that
right like because he has this whole
story about how he went on that crazy
run in insanity but it was because he
had no other choice he had to ball out
yeah but then as he got more famous he
talks about this where he was like i
just didn't believe in myself like i
just was second guessing everything that
i did and therefore my performance
exactly and he's like i know everybody
around me knows i'm way better than this
but i just couldn't get over that
anxiety that like pressure it's his
parents stop beating them exactly that's
why you gotta beat your kids y'all
here's a question following up to that
then so
is alcohol banned in the olympics like
if you get caught with alcohol in your
pee do you get in trouble i don't think
so no but it's also like but then i've
heard liquid courage right so if that's
the case how come athletes don't drink
and then perform
hand-eye coordination
imagine imagine they drink before woohoo
they're
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they just they just never let go
or he thinks the pole vaults the javelin
i can throw it
just like a balance beam
you're like this on it dude imagine
imagine like the high bar in gymnastics
and they're drunk and he lets go at the
wrong time and he just shoots into the
air that's what we need for the olympics
we need drunk olympics
and that will show how good you are
yeah here's a little kicker it says
cannabis remains on a list of banned
substances that the world anti-doping
agency released shortly after the token
olympics but the agency said in
september that it will review the ban
citing requests from a number of
stakeholders in international athletics
interestingly once money's involved cbd
companies yeah hey but you know what the
other thing though too about the shikari
thing is like people talk about uh like
drug testing in general for professional
sports and they say like it's kind of an
intelligence test it's like you everyone
knows that like right when it's going to
come around kind of like there's like
there's ways to find out when you get
tested and everyone dopes i heard and i
exactly everyone dub you like in part of
me feels like
shikari is probably not the only athlete
that uses marijuana yeah for sure not so
part of the argument too is like
you didn't try to like like guess i'm a
fake p
i know you couldn't she didn't try hard
at night it's part of the game already
and if everyone smokes weed in the
olympics like we're talking strictly
olympics performance enhancing drugs in
professional sports in general is like
is very prominent so part of it too is
like
you miss your opportunity for gold medal
because you're smoking pot and like
that's not really the issue but it's
like you didn't try to pass the drug
test but then when you okay as far as i
know when you smoke pot though do you
want to do things
that's true so that could have been the
issue but if you're if you're the best
if you know like oh i just broke a
record and i'm gonna beat every her
story that she was smoking weed because
she was like dealing with depression
from her mom yeah okay yeah see there's
stuff like that too for sure when i
smoke yeah
there was a gymnast that got caught with
adderall and that's a bad substance in
uh olympics
but she also has extreme adhd so i think
there's also like um there's certain
things you can take with prescriptions
so things that are already complicated
is even that much more complicated if
she got the weed as a prescription maybe
it would have been okay shikari got
glaucoma that's why that's why she's
smoking pot yeah she has cataracts if
she had it then maybe it would have been
okay she really does
i'm trying to out i'm trying to savor it
bro okay it sounds like wait i thought
she said she because her mom she's all
oh wait i have glaucoma actually
okay okay are you good
she should have just said that it's like
what the nfl does like nfl players will
say like every year the uh like the list
comes out like what the band substances
we do everything right up into the line
of banned substance and then the next
year if something's banned then we don't
we do less yeah that's cool do
everything up to that you know because
they want every edge possible
so like you know and i don't know that
nfl players will smoke weed because they
probably want that killer
instinct and where if it's if that's
like dull
[Music]
rehab they're probably smoking to relax
drugs affect people in different ways
you can totally be like super focused
productive on weed like it just depends
on like your usage and your your intake
ability i just get paranoid and tired
i'm pretty productive on weed i think
that i think they were just hard on her
too because it's a very plain breaching
of very strict obvious rules yeah
because i i used to work with olympians
when i was composing for them and they
told me that like they were like hey
sorry at any time someone could just
show up and go all right let's do the
test like any time they could collect
two in the morning yeah because they
have to tell the um the the committee
where they are at all times the
whereabouts so that the drug test people
can find them and they'll just be like
are you gonna pee in this thing someone
they have like a male and a female to
watch you do it it's really really
strict so it's like i think it's the
disrespect of like you knew this was the
case and you still did it is why they
were like no you're not [ __ ] going
olympics it's more of like you can't
make us look like asses by just saying
oh i was like depressed i smoked in
america yeah now the committee looks
like [ __ ]
no power you know how big that story got
yeah like that story was huge didn't
want her to like to look like she's
taking away like like usurping their
authority because that's really like
that's you didn't really do anything
that's a weird ego trip she did
something so like nothing and then of
course you're not going to get their
power take an example unfortunately
exactly
action two wasn't the best no yeah it's
not and that's not the time to talk
about should we reform this law after
you got caught doing it like this is the
worst time we should reform it and then
smoke all day to celebrate
yeah on camera baby
[Music]
you